hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in his famous
spiritual autobiography the confessions
in book 2 st. Augustine
recalls an incident that's often called
the incident of the pear tree which
takes place when he is a really not
quite a young man he's still at youth
and what we would call this nowadays is
juvenile delinquency he is out with a
bunch of friends and these are
troublemakers but he's kind of a
troublemaker as well he had on the way
home these are kids who have already
gotten in trouble you know before on the
way home they see a pear tree and they
say let's rob that pear tree we're not
actually gonna eat the pears we'll just
take a few bites and we'll throw the
rest of the pigs and what's wrong with
this well it's not there pear tree so
this is an act of theft and theft was
taken very seriously in ancient times we
tend to have a bit more of a lack of
day's achill attitude towards towards
theft and towards property then ancients
did for her Augustine this was something
that was definitely wrong and the
question that he's asking himself is
what about basic human motivation what
is it that makes us do wrong things
so he's extrapolating from
incident he's using it as an example to
try to figure out what drives us what
drives us to do the wrong thing so he's
asking himself this question why and he
frames it for himself in terms of what
was it in that act that he actually
loved or enjoyed or desired what
motivated him to do something that he
clearly knew was wrong so that's a very
interesting question to begin with and
he carries out this analysis of what was
going on in his mind comparing his own
case to that of others so he begins by
reflecting on what motivates people to
do wrong actions in many cases
well desire or fear desire to have
certain Goods which you know it's wrong
for us to have not in themselves but at
that time or in that way or because of
the things that we have to do in order
to get them or fear fear of losing the
goods that we have fear of not enjoying
future Goods that we have lined up for
ourselves or whatever anticipating what
are the sort of things that we we feel
the stories well wealth is a one example
people do a lot of bad things for money
or to hold on to money fame honor
pleasure beautiful things and security
so these these provide a sufficient
explanation when somebody does something
wrong you can ask yourself why did that
person kill that other person well he
thought that they were going to kill him
he was afraid or he wanted to get the
inheritance of the person who's you know
will he was in who he poisoned so wealth
or he wanted to sleep with that man's
wife and the guy came in so he killed
him
you know and we can do this with not
only with murder
we do this for theft we can do this with
everything that we think is a bad Act
many bad acts can be explained that
simply there's a there's an
intelligibility to them
so our Mis team is looking at this
particular act and he says well you know
what about these pears were they pretty
were they desirable well there are pears
so you know they're they have a nice
taste to them and you know even a visual
appearance Augustine is very good about
describing those sorts of things but he
didn't really want them for that so what
was going on he says I wanted to commit
the act of theft these pears were
valuable to me only insofar as they
allowed me to transgress to do something
that I I knew and felt was wrong when I
was doing it along with my companions
with whom I did it so what's going on in
there
he says well this is what I'm really
desired that's what I wanted to take
pleasure in let's think about the act of
theft or the act of doing there's no
intrinsic beauty to committing a wrong
action you know there may be some
effects that come about like these sort
of things over here where you know I
kill a person because it allows me to
protect a great work of art or or to
realize this this other beautiful thing
but in that case it's not the act itself
that has any sort of beauty to it it's
what's being protected or enabled or or
gotten through that so the act itself
has no beauty it doesn't even really
have an intrinsic desirability to it so
what's going on there beautiful
while I just even considers another
possibility he says you know in the case
of a lot of vices and it gives you a lot
of examples of those which I don't need
to to go over in detail you can read the
passage for yourself he says that this
theft did not even have the false or
shadowy Beauty that belongs to these
vices and why do these vices have a kind
of beauty well because they're kind of
an imitation of God and in one way or
another so cry for example pride doesn't
actually measure up to God but it makes
the person who's engaging in it and even
some people witnessing it say wow
there's there's really something there
and Augustine thinks that it does so
through imitation of God or anger for
example the vise of anger is a problem
because you know anger wants to punish
and there's a certain you know
attractiveness to that but really only
the divine can can punish and we could
go down a whole bunch of examples of
that
does that work for stealing not really
does that work we could pick a few other
things too does that work for lying
no because the divine what would God
steal right so it doesn't even have this
and yet
there is going to be kind of an
imitation of the divine there Argosy and
says that what I wanted to do was to
break the law to break the law
I wanted to transgress I wanted to do
what was wrong because I was being
attracted to doing it because it was
wrong so there is going to be a kind of
imitation of God involved there an
imitation of the divine omnipotence and
the divine freedom but it's it's a mere
shadowy imitation and this leads us to
the really interesting
metaphysical point that yeah all I've
seen is gonna make really what the theft
is is a big nothing and the answer to
what is it that he really desires about
this nothing anyway I said well how can
he have any sort of desire then what can
be motivating him well this is where
Augustine is doing something really
interesting when it comes to the
metaphysics of human action we are
capable of turning ourselves away from
higher Goods and towards lesser Goods
and even making that turning itself to
be something that we sort of invest
ourselves in that we want for its own
sake and when we do that we are you
might say participating in a kind of
nothingness the story gets even more
interesting because he'll say a little
bit after that and I've run out of room
on the chalkboard but it's going to
involve another nothing he says well why
the hell did I do with them and he's
reconsidering it and he's trying to you
know expand it to encompass the entire
situation says well I was doing it with
my companions and this isn't something
that I would have done by myself as
screwed up as I was I wouldn't have that
they actually sought out that nothing on
my own so companionship now does that
put us back here no because what was the
companionship in it was in doing the
wrong things so that companionship
itself he says isn't nothing there's two
nothing's there the act itself a theft
and the companionship and these two
nothings you might say well how do they
differ
well they don't differ in anything
actually you know you might say
nothing's squared this is what led him
to do what he
did does this provide a full adequate
explanation for a human action does it
provide complete intelligibility the way
that's saying well you did it for the
sake of honor does Augustine says no but
this is actually an achievement in
understanding the way human beings make
decisions function work things out it's
one of the potentialities that we have
for going wrong so to sum up wider
Augustine's field of the pair's
ultimately because we're able to turn
ourselves towards nothing